talk about the ultimate B Day
celebration sophie Turner crashed the
Jonas Brothers concert stage in
Washington DC on Thursday night
alongside fellow J sister Danielle to
celebrate Joe's 30th birthday the
onstage surprise came after Sophie
showed these sweet messages about her
man on Instagram calling Joe the best
thing that's ever happened to me Joe's
birthday festivities first kicked off on
Wednesday midair on a private plane with
a sing-along to tayo cruises at dynamite
and continued after the concert on
Thursday with this game of Thrones
inspired cake with Joe in the Iron
Throne and Sophia by his side fun fact
Joe was a fan of the show long before he
and Sophie got together sure I would
love to be part of good game of Thrones
I'm a huge fan
no Sophie and her sisters-in-law
Danielle and Priyanka Chopra have been
tagging along on the Jonas Brothers
happiness begins to her when they can
once upon a time is just like the boys
your parents you know your brother going
on the road down you have like the why
it's an army et was with the guys on
night 1 in Miami where they had this to
say about bringing their families on the
road are you scheduling the wives houses
work the watch being here ah what shows
and how do you love it they're all I
mean they're all here here tonight which
would be good and our parents aren't
sound Frankie's and sound and we got the
extended family it's like an it is an
army we're on our VIP section is gonna
be pouring over those seats are going to
your VIP see that bar back there yeah we
got a nice uh bar it's pretty much yeah
it's gonna be a party